hoje eu tô aqui pra começar com uma
pergunta muito simples eu quero saber se
alguém aqui está vivendo a vida que
queria viver de droga
cacá silva
quando estava com 15 ou 16 anos tinha
dois sonhos era engenheiro civil e o
outro era fazer intercâmbio na
inglaterra
com 17 anos eu passei no vestibular da
universidade estadual de maringá do
curso de engenharia civil e com três
meses de curso
eu tive a certeza de que eu não queria
mas sem dinheiro no trono eu ainda
tentei voltar para o curso
e aí eu tive mais três meses agoniantes
eu falei não eu não quero mais isso eu
não quero mais engenheiro civil rafael
não quer mais e isso eu não sou
engenheiro civil eu não fiz intercâmbio
na inglaterra
passados esses acontecimentos
eu tomei duas decisões para minha vida
eu decidi que eu ia trabalhar com que eu
gostasse de fazer que eu ia conhecer o
mundo
mas não é só conhecer o mundo não é só
viajar cada lugar que eu visitasse eu ia
morar naquele lugar nem que por 10 ou 20
dias mas ele vivenciar aquele lugar em
2004 a fotografia entrou na minha vida
eu comecei a estudar por hobby e por
prazer
em 2007 eu comecei a faculdade de
administração de empresas na
universidade estadual de maringá também
no primeiro ano eu tive a chance de
fazer uma entrevista de emprego foi a
minha primeira entrevista de emprego
fui eu para uma estação aduaneira para
trabalhar num cargo de auxiliar
administrativo
eu fiz a entrevista e foi aprovado nessa
entrevista e uma segunda feira eu
comecei a trabalhar e eu digo pra vocês
que foi um dos dias mais agoniantes que
eu tive na minha vida eu vi trancado no
escritório fazendo serviços burocráticos
na frente de um computador tendo que
bater cartão tem horário para uns a
aquilo miyagi o amigo e agonia de um
jeito que no outro dia eu tenho que
confessar que eu fiz uma coisa terrível
eu recorri a minha mãe porque mãe serve
pra isso também
a liga no trabalho e fala que eu estava
doente mas é mentira eu não tava doente
óbvio mas achei que me livrar daquilo e
no terceiro dia eu pedi as contas
o mais engraçado foi mulher do
financeiro fazendo um acerto comigo eu
recebi 12 e 50 por esse dia de trabalho
e aqui a minha carteira de trabalho para
comprovar pra vocês
a admissão de um dia e dois dias depois
da demissão nunca mais usei essa
carteira de trabalho pra nada só esses
dias que eu fui na minha gaveta e peguei
para tirar essa foto para provar pra
vocês que eu não estou inventando
paralelo a isso eu comecei a colocar as
fotos que eu vinha fazendo aquele hobby
que eu tinha eu comecei a divulgar na
internet e as pessoas começaram a se
interessar por isso
e de repente começaram a me chamar para
fazer alguns trabalhos de fotografia e
quando eu me dei conta
eu tava ganhando dinheiro com o que eu
gostava de fazer aquilo foi sensacional
para mim e aí eu decidi que tudo que eu
aprendesse no curso de administração eu
ia tentar levar a fotografia ea
demografia eu resolvi fazer um plano de
negócios para abrir o meu primeiro
estúdio em dezembro de 2010 eu me formei
em janeiro de 2011 estava com uma
empresa aberta como estúdio montado e aí
eu tracei uma meta
a minha meta era eu preciso e eu quero
viver de fotografia de moda é o que eu
gosto de fotografar
até então eu fotografava de tudo um
pouco já fotografei batizado de
fotografia aniversário de criança
já fotografei bodas de qualquer coisa já
fotografei peça de caminhão cirurgia de
catarata de cachorro
eu só não fotografei velório porque não
me chamar que eu acho que se tivesse
chamado eu ia eu precisava fazer
dinheiro precisava levantar fazer aquela
empresa movimentar e aí dois anos depois
atingiu o objetivo que era viver de
fotografia de moda e não precisa mais
fotografar o que eu não tinha muita
vontade e aí a gente pensa missão
cumprida né não
foi nesse momento que eu descobri que eu
sou um constante inquieta descobrir
na zona de conforto não é pro rafael e
aí depois de algumas frustrações a minha
vida teve uma virada muito grande no dia
muito simples eu estava no meu estúdio
fazendo algumas atividades rotineiras do
trabalho estava numa tarde tranquila eu
peguei meus hds comecei a rever alguns
arquivos organizar e quando me dei conta
estava apagando fox e aquilo pra mim foi
como insight eu pensei meu deus eu estou
pagando algo que eu comecei a fazer que
era pra ser histórico
eu comecei a fotografar para que as
pessoas pudessem usar esse trabalho
daqui a 100 200 quem sabe mil anos e eu
tô me desfazendo disso está certo
aquilo foi como se eu tivesse atingido o
ápice e despencado acima e esse tombo eu
muito muito só que foi nessa época que
eu tive a chance de fazer minha primeira
viagem para fora do país
de lá pra cá eu fui morar em alguns
lugares a argentina é a lógica holanda
frança e irlanda país de gales e
adivinha eu fui para a inglaterra
eu consegui eu fotografei muito nesses
lugares e fotografei muito cotidiano
desses lugares eu me inserir nas
culturas locais pra conseguir trazer o
que estava buscando
só que ainda aquilo me inquietava eu
ainda não me sentia completo fazendo
aqui eu ainda precisava de algo mas e aí
depois de muitas noites mal dormidas
eu resolvi que eu precisava fazer algo
pelo mundo e que eu precisava fazer a
diferença na minha vida e na vida das
pessoas
eu precisava curar aquele vazio que
tinha descoberto em mim naquela tarde
tranquila
então eu resolvi conversar com um amigo
meu o lucas
resumindo o lucas tem uma empresa
chamada help a cada camiseta carrel que
vende eles fazem a doação de um uniforme
para uma criança que esteja matriculado
na escola esteja freqüentando eu
conversei com lucas e foi lucas eu quero
fazer parte disso eu quero participar de
uma ação social
eu quero ver como funciona eu preciso
disso eu preciso fotografar isso
conversando com ele a gente estava
pensando em alguns lugares que a gente
podia ir início uma catástrofe que
assolou nepal março e abril de 2015 uma
série de terremotos que devastou o país
mais de 8500 pessoas mortas e
aproximadamente 8 milhões de pessoas
afetadas
um desastre ea gente teve a chance de ir
ao nepal dois meses depois disso para
visitar uma velhinha muito remota
chamada villa 4 para chegar nessa vila
foi bem difícil a gente percorreu 200
quilômetros de jipe em 8 horas uma
estrada muito sinuosa muito perigosa na
beira de precipícios
depois a gente percorreu as duas horas
de caminhada pela montanha à noite na
chegada à vila mais dn
a gente ainda não chegou na vila papi no
outro dia às 10 horas de caminhada pela
montanha era época de monções que a pior
época para se fazer esse tipo de
caminhada no palco a gente enfrentou de
tudo no mesmo dia frio calor chuva
sanguessuga desgaste físico tudo depois
de 10 horas a gente finalmente chegou
naquela via linha que a gente estava
buscando chamada patrick os dias que eu
passei na vila padre eu pude entender
com vive uma comunidade num lugar tão
distante um lugar tão remoto e aí eu
comecei a ouvir algumas histórias dos
locais porque a gente dormia o tempo
todo estava com eles e dormir na casa
deles dos nativos e duas histórias me
chamaram atenção que eu quero
compartilhar com vocês
uma delas é de que algumas crianças
precisavam caminhar de duas a três horas
pela montanha para chegar na escolinha
da vila e não é só caminhar
elas tinham que caminhar fazendo trilha
trazendo todo aquele esforço físico que
a gente vinha fazendo e quando acabava a
aula elas precisavam voltar pra casa e
quando ela chegava em casa à noite e não
tem energia
elas precisavam estudar não tinha luz
então elas usavam como na beira de um
fogão a lenha
detalhe não terminar dentro de casa
você consegue imaginar a fumaça que fica
nesse ambiente
eu dormia em uma casa dessas eu posso
dizer e afirmar para vocês que é
praticamente impossível você ficar com
os olhos abertos
agora imagine estudar a outra história
que me chama muito a atenção foi que o
pemba open bar o nosso guia que se
tornou um amigo de vida pra mim é open
bar sherpa ele contou pra gente que
depois dos terremotos
o mundo estava enviando ajuda do nepal
porém muita gente estava enviando arroz
de vinha olival produz arroz
ele não tinha o que fazer com esse
alimento eles estavam fazendo vinho de
arroz para estragar
e foi aí que eu entendi que pra você
ajudar alguém não basta você querer você
primeiro precisa identificar a real
necessidade dessa pessoa dessa
comunidade
quando comecei a viajar para lugares
assim eu sabia que eu podia impactar de
duas formas uma dela
uma delas era estando lá com a minha
presença
indo para um lugar onde as pessoas
talvez nem saibam onde ao brasil mas que
elas elas ficam realmente muito gratos
em saber que tem alguém de muito longe
se preocupando com elas e querendo o bem
estar delas a outra forma era trazendo
essas imagens pra cá divulgando por
redes sociais e tentando impactar as
pessoas e talvez causar um sentimento de
solidariedade e talvez uma pessoa a cada
mil que visse a foto em que ela tivesse
vontade de ajudar alguém nem que fosse
um vizinho
a gente não precisa viajar o nepal para
evitar alguém
às vezes o nosso vizinho está precisando
de alguma coisa eu não sabia muito bem o
que eu ia fazer com esse material era
tudo novo pra mim e quando me dei conta
a mídia nacional tava dando atenção para
o trabalho dos dois brasileiros que
haviam ido para o nepal após os
terremotos
isso foi muito bom porque foi um
objetivo sendo atingida era o objetivo
de disseminar as imagens de levar essas
imagens para o maior número de pessoas
possível e aí eu me dei conta que eu
pedi um pouco mais além
então eu criei um negócio onde o
comercializo fotos em formato de quadros
e eu destino 50% de todo o lucro que o
recado pra comunidades necessitadas e
que enxerga uma real necessidade
nessa comunidade
depois do nepal eu tive a chance de ir
para a áfrica
seis meses depois tive contato com dois
países
o quênia ea etiópia eu tive contato com
tribos indígenas desses lugares com ongs
muito importantes como o living positivo
e quênia é uma ong que ampara em poderá
mulheres com hiv positivo
tive contato com projetos sociais dentro
de que dera que a maior favela africana
e tudo isso fez eu tenho certeza de que
cada comunidade tem uma necessidade
distinta quando cheguei ao brasil depois
da áfrica
eu tenho um nome a tudo isso então
nasceu a walking in com o que é uma
analogia a caminhar em inglês que é o
sair da zona de conforto é o ir e vir em
uma pesquisa rápida pela internet e
descobri por obra do destino que o alto
com 1 em vocês
significa é uma variação de wake up caiu
como uma luva para mim porque é o
caminhar
o despertar é você despertar para novas
realidades para novas culturas
exatamente um ano depois que eu fui o
nepal ao que conseguiu enviar sua
primeira doação
vocês lembram da história das crianças
estudam na beira do fogão a lenha
então baseado nessa necessidade que eu
cheguei a gente fez a doação de um
sistema de energia solar para a
escolinha da vila pátria levando energia
para essas crianças
a gente pode posteriormente levar
baterias luminárias recarregáveis para
essas crianças poderem estudar em casa
ou algum outro tipo de protótipo ou quem
sabe que é um sonho grande que eu sei
que é o que pode chegar a levar energia
para cada morador dessa vila
já pensou que sensacional seria isso
você levar o desenvolvimento para uma
vila e seria demais
realmente a nossa vida é feita de
escolhas
cada escolha que a gente faz a gente tem
que fazer uma renúncia
eu falo que algumas pessoas escolheram
casar ter filhos ter casa na praia a
ganhar terreno
viajar pelo litoral e eu escolhi e em
busca de coisas boas a gente todo mundo
pensa que só tem coisa ruim acontecendo
eu escolhi ir em busca de sorrisos
adaptar
hoje eu olho nos olhos de cada um de
vocês eu digo que estou vivendo a vida
que eu queria viver uma série